sur ce plateau camille sari professeur
des universités consultant en relations
internationales et auteur de l'algérie
histoire secrète d'un naufrage annoncé
aux éditions l'harmattan bonjour merci
je vais être avec nous donc selon human
rights watch des dizaines d'arrestations
se poursuivre après l'élection
présidentielle du 12 décembre dernier
même s'ils avaient plus de 70 activistes
qui ont été relâchés certains restent
encore incarcérés qu'est ce qu'il faut à
quoi est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre ces
prochains jours par rapport à ces
chiffres est ce que ces chiffres peuvent
descendre ou au contraire augmenté le
pari du pouvoir actuel
c'est à la fois de donner l'illusion
qu'il y aura des changements au niveau
de la constitution
et là tous les jours dans les médias
officiels algériens en détail les
modifications qui seront proposés c'est
à dire la lutte contre la corruption la
limitation de mandats présidentiels de
plus de liberté et cetera donc c'est
alléchant quand on voit tout ce
catalogue c'est un vrai catalogue de de
promesses mais ça c'est comme ça ça va
dans le bon sens ça va dans le bon sens
mais le problème toujours escurat une
application de ces principes
constitutionnels dans le passé déjà il
ya eu beaucoup de promesses sur le
papier c'est en a vu d un appel à plus
de démocratie de la presse et caetera de
liberté d'expression mais dans la
réalité il y a rien qui change et réa
qui changent et même la situation va
s'aggraver sur le plan de l'intimidation
et des arrestations
parce que le pouvoir n'a pas autre
guillemets d'autre choix que d'aller
vers à une tentative de jupes
il est ce mouvement qui est toujours là
c'est beaucoup 11 mois de manifestations
hebdomadaires c'est énorme et donc le
pari c'est de l'affaiblir ou aux îles
ils ont parié sur tous les tours tout
les toutes les manigances par exemple
des élections présidentielles
la disparition du président en fin de
lettre de chef d'état major gaïd salah
toutes les restructurations qui a usé de
l'armée tout ça pour dire voilà nous
commençons une page nouvelle l'appel au
dialogue mais les algérie ali hajir elle
ne se trompe pas parce que pour eux ils
savent très bien que le problème et les
foncièrement politique mais surtout
économique c'est à dire plus le problème
est politique on l'a vu le mouvement du
et rac
commence à essayer de se politiser on a
vu dans le sujet certains partis de
l'opposition qui tente de se fédérer
pour proposer une alternative est ce que
ça c'est viable
ça c'est le point faible de irak de
cette révolution c'est que il n'est pas
structure hier pas de partis
d'opposition parce que bouteflika il
s'est vraiment déployer à museler toute
opposition à l'intérieur du pays à
acheter aussi la paix sociale etc
donc il y a il n'y a pas une
organisation mais ceci dit est-ce que
s'il y avait un parti où des partis
peut-être que ça aurait créé des
clivages
moi j'ai proposé dans mon ouvrage une
solution vraiment intéressante que je
pense via ce faisable c'est que
l'ensemble de la population algérienne
elise à une ce que j'ai appelé une
assemblée nationale démocratique et
citoyen de c'est à dire eux de ne pas
aller dans le jeu du pouvoir et de 2,2
ce qu'on appelle une votation citoyenne
ça existait dans beaucoup de pays
la votation citoyenne ça s'organise il
ya des moyens techniques qui peuvent
faire des débats repas la télévision
nationale mais par les médias il faut
qu' il faut que ce mouvement se soit
organisé mais il faut qu'ils aient des
représentants c'est ça le poite
essentiel justement parmi les
représentants ce que ça peut être
abdel goual affaire c'est oui ou encore
samir ben larbi des personnes qui ont
été emprisonnés
c'est me reviennent derby qui attend son
verdict que risque-t-il est ce qu'ils
peuvent incarner le futur
il ya quand même un problème de comment
dire dakar nation de l'opposition parce
qu'il ya karim tabbou qui représente la
kabylie qui est incarcéré il
et puis un débat il ya beaucoup de
clivage dans ce sens et pour moi le
problème n'est pas le choix de telle ou
telle personne c'est ce que je pense je
rentre je suis pas un politique je suis
un expert et je le vois du point de vue
de l'analyse de poids de vue de
l'analyse c'est quelle que soit la
personne qui sera élu ou désigné ou
incarner le mouvement bain d'une manière
ou d'une autre si elle elle n'a pas le
contrôle de tous les rouages et en
premier lieu la pression de l'armée
parce que le pouvoir actuellement il est
quand même entre les mains de l'armée
même le président le président teboul
qui a été élu mais à mon avis il a été
lu par 8 % des électeurs parce qu'on a
gonflé et sa phase a été gonflé le taux
de participation il a pas beaucoup de
marge de manoeuvre dans qu'il obéit à
l'agenda de l'armée et on a eu des
comptes-rendus donc des réunions de
l'état-major le soir de la dudh et c'est
donc un peu suspect de deux guides salah
a en a vu comment il s'était l'armée qui
désignait les ministres qui désignait
selon leur intérêt à eux donc il ya un
probable les batiks qui quand même une
problématique de partage du pouvoir
donc il faut une représentation une
assemblée nationale pour pâques aussi de
deux citoyennes
merci c'est le mot de la fin
merci camille sari d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
l'auteur de l'algérie histoire secrète
d'un naufrage annoncé aux éditions
l'harmattan